des jeunes 13 80 à quoi deux trois ans
quand je vends toi fons tu fonces cher
journal en attendant que le garçon que
j'aime bien et qui m'aiment bien mais
qui n'arrive pas à quitter sa copine
quitte sa copine j'ai parlé un garçon
qui n'a pas de copine a quitté sur une
application de rencontres populaires
bon c'était surtout pour que mes potes
arrête de me dire qu'il faudrait que
j'ai une vie sexuelle plus remplies oui
je sais le terme et comme mes amies très
mal choisi ce toit sur la photo c'est ça
je le disais c'est vite trop bizarre on
trouve ça m'a rendu justement mais cette
fois j'avais bien envie de me faire
offrir un verre après avoir insisté pour
qu'il me laisse payer bien sûr que même
pas du coup on a peut-être payé mais moi
je préfère gens c'est wayne mais moi
j'aime bien ok way n'iront pas en tout
cas chaleur je veux avec plaisir je
t'invite à bas ok d'accord fera tout vu
ouais ok mais secoués comme ça c'est
plus simple plus simple et serait plus
simple de dire mais alors je faisais moi
ça n'a pas du tout fonctionné
passez-moi gp aussi tour sinon il m'a
demandé si j'acceptais qu ils
m'embrassent alors je lui dis oui oui
sur les lèvres
[Musique]
tu peux plus face moi je jouis est-ce
que je peux témoigner des chamois oui
bien parti pour oui oui à la face alors
j'ai continué à dire oui oui plusieurs
fois encore oui encore est ce que ça ne
soit que je trouve une question est-ce
que tu passes à la main ici j'ai
prétexté que j'avais un rendez vous très
tôt le lendemain matin mais la vérité
c'est que j'avais juste à te retrouver
mon chien il a proposé de me payer un
taxi mais vraiment j'avais trop dit oui
alors que ça me serve de leçon ne jamais
simuler afin de garder quelques oui pour
se faire offrir le taxi
[Musique]